[Music]
when I was young I was fascinated by
planes and wanted to be a pilot I first
got a chance to fly on a plane when I
was in middle school and what I remember
is how smooth the ride was I did not
even feel that we were moving when I
grew up I had a chance to look inside
the cockpit and I saw how complex it was
but still the experience of flying was
made smooth and easy for the passengers
and that is how Google cloud platform
operates
it has complexity inside but for the
user it is simple and easy to use and it
is reliable like planes - hi everyone I
am Amit Singhal technical leader at
Google today along with my colleagues
we'll talk about how Google Software
Defined approach behind its
infrastructure and products make it
resilient scalable in high performance
we will deep dive into Andromeda virtual
networking and also talk about front-end
systems that route all incoming traffic
in the end we will talk about some of
the networking products Google cloud
platform at high level comprises of
following compute which has compute
engine App Engine container engine and
cloud functions then we have storage
which has several products like cloud
SQL BigTable cloud datastore spanner
etcetera networking with infrastructure
for virtualization and load balancers
and several products like cloud VPN
routers firewalls etcetera analytics
with products like bigquery data flow
data prop machine learning etc when key
advantage Google Cloud customers get is
reliability and scale of running on same
shared infrastructure that powers all
Google services like search ads Maps
Gmail
etc built with years of experience in
state-of-the-art technology Google has
been a pioneer in large-scale
distributed systems for more than a
decade many of Google's innovations have
completely changed the standard
computing paradigms and spawned new
industries MapReduce started Big Data
revolution cloud dataflow is built over
that BigTable was one of the first no
sequel database implementations and
cloud BigTable is built over that then
we have cloud GCS our Colossus cloud
bigquery is built over Dremel spanner is
a wide area consistent database service
that allows you to run transactions
across the globe and cloud spanner is
provided over that all this services
provided through DCP api's we use
software-defined approach across all
verticals of cloud and they share
similar concepts we would love to talk
about all the areas but in the interest
of time we'll focus more on the
networking in the store Google is
constantly innovating in networking
space this is a timeline of the major
milestones we have taken
software-defined approach early on and
almost everything we do maglev is a
software load balancer that routes all
incoming traffic to correct backends
before is our van network built using
esteemed principles Jupiter is our
software-defined data center networking
and Andromeda is our software-defined
network virtualization technology why
Google cloud networking it provides high
throughput up to 16 gigabit per second
and under hundred microseconds later see
between vm's
you can spin up thousands of VMs within
few minutes and we provide hitless
upgrade and feature allows without
impacting customer workloads with our VM
migration
technology one of the key advantages of
our networks are that they are global
which allows customers to have VMs in
different regions communicate over
private ip's and to provide network
functions as a service like load
balancing routing security CDN etcetera
we talked about why and now let's look
at what is Google cloud networking like
I said we had Google use
software-defined networking as the end
in everything we do for networking but
Google cloud networking is not just that
first of all it is built upon our state
of the art when connecting our
state-of-the-art data centers it is
network virtualization and isolation
using Sdn principles it has to scale to
support thousands of VMs for thousands
of customers and provide customized
April functionality through API is all
this together
make Google Cloud Network so
software-defined network virtualization
what are the benefits for using it
provides faster provisioning times with
centralized controller faster rollout of
new features without depending on new
hardware high availability using
hierarchical control plane in next few
slides we'll talk about how virtual
networks are different from physical
networks and what are the unique
challenges that trade overlay over steel
networks our physical network and it
also talked about our centralized
hierarchical control plane some
high-level background on how physical
networks look you have racks of servers
we call them hosts here shown in green
boxes they connect the top of the racks
which towards towards connect to each
other through one or more routers in the
middle important property of these
networks is addressed aggregation and
locality
that limits the radius of lair to
broadcast domain and that is also used
by distributed routing protocols and
switches to learn and make forwarding
decisions with cloud physical data
center networks become multi-tenant you
can imagine there is a logical switch
per virtual network now one way to
support this is by extending the whole
stack to become aware of multi-tenancy
and use tenant key in this case we call
it v net here for virtual network in
making all forwarding decisions now this
need changes to physical switches and
routers and also make routing protocols
to carry this new information but even
if we do that what makes this approach
difficult is that as customers spin up
new VMs they can be scheduled anywhere
on the physical network depending on the
availability and there is no
location-based address aggregation
network virtualization takes a different
approach instead of relying on dynamic
discovery based protocols it creates a
logical overlay for each customer hiding
details of the physical network using an
capsulation and host port information
for each VM point-to-point flows are
created between VMs now centralized
controller is key to implementing such
approach now let's look at work flow for
VM creation and network provisioning in
this case owner of the orange network
wants to add one more VM he sends the
request to configuration manager which
calls compute control plane to start a
VM on some hosts with available capacity
that information is given to
configuration manager which calls the
network control plane with the host port
information of the newly created VM it
then sends a message to all hosts which
has VMs from this network
point-to-point flows are created from
this new VM to the existing VMs in this
slide I'd like to emphasize the
hierarchical implementation of our
configuration and control plane
configuration plane serves all user
requests by calling appropriate back in
modules it is divided into three levels
global regional and zonal even back-end
control plane is divided into three
levels global regional and zonah user
requests are routed to various back-end
jobs at different hierarchies now goal
is to keep most configuration and
provisioning at zonal level to limit the
blast radius of any failure and then
regional and only few services to be
global when necessary we talked about
configuration now let's look at control
and data plain fabric manager gets all
requests for network provisioning again
the hosts are divided at regional and
zonal level their VM controllers which
manages all the VMS inside customer
Network and this VM controllers are zola
it creates flows between all the
endpoints on a virtual network so these
endpoints can communicate our next
speaker will talk in more detail about
this part there cloud front-end tasks
that provide connectivity to Google
services for VMs through internal
network without having to traverse
through public network end points inside
virtual network can send traffic to
Internet through Google edge routers and
finally all incoming traffic first hits
network load balancer and appropriately
routed to correct end point in either
customer network or Google front-end
tasks for Google services and now I'll
hand over to my colleague and next
speaker krishnan talk more about
Andromeda virtual networking
thanks man in this portion the talk I
will be covering details on the network
virtualization of the structure the
Paris TCP there's a great opportunity
for us especially me to represent the
work of an amazing team here at Google
so network virtualization for GCP
internally is known as Andromeda
Andromeda powers the virtual networking
infrastructure and not apart network
product offerings
I mean without Google fellow as
presented in Andromeda at onf earlier
and today we will be uncovering the nuts
and bolts of how Andromeda is actually
built especially its core features that
allows us to build scalable and
high-performance systems so what you see
behind me is GZ piece a network it is
one of the largest networks among cloud
providers it is globally spread out
there are six regions 18 zones and we
will be announcing 12 more regions in
2017 network virtualization is to build
to make it easy for you the customer to
leverage this amazing network this talk
is in two halves
first I'll be doing a deep dive into our
control plane first I'll be talking
about how we provide isolation across
virtual networks in this example there
are two virtual networks which share the
same physical infrastructure I will be
giving details and how the network
virtualization allows these networks
that have their own 10 space I will also
be talking about how we can scale up
on-demand
TCP we have done experiments we've can
show hundred K of the amps can be spun
up in hundred and eighty four
milliseconds I should also be going into
details and how we achieve our high
availability targets do three nines in a
single zone four nines in a region and
finites globally next I'd also be going
into details about a unique data plane
our radial plane has core network
functions baked directly into it
for example load balancing we're also
constantly evolving and we are building
new network functions into our data
plane I'll be talking into details and
how we achieve that but using live
migration and also what we call hitless
data
upgrades so let's dive right in
as Amit mentioned our control plane is
built as a hierarchy sits at the very
top where we call cluster manager a
cluster manager performs many tasks it
is responsible for configuring things
like storage compute and in our case
networking below that sits the fabric
manager and you can see a team going on
here it's against split up into regional
and zonal control planes Andromeda comes
below it which is VM controllers and
what the fabric management VM
controllers job is to expose a high
level API which is used to configure
that should the virtual networks and
also different network functions right
below it says the ofe which is the open
flow layer it takes our API abstractions
and then converts them into open flow of
programming constructs that we can use
to program a switching layer switching
layer shown here is built directly into
each VM host it has a programmable
switch which is based on open V switch
and it has a core data plane which is
responsible for packet processing so now
let's take a deeper look on how we
actually achieve the scale of a control
plane as zoomed in here is zonal view of
our control plane and a single force
it's managing his zone shares the same
hardware failure domain and also has the
same network connectivity to guard
against machine failures the VM controls
are replicated it has one singly master
that's a selected master and two
standbys to take orally given time you
also sharded the office and single ofe
maintains shards multiple VM hosts
shards and we take the sharding concept
one step further we replicate our entire
control plane so that each VM C also
manages other racks another set of hosts
this allows us to smear processing
across these different replicas finally
this also lasts what easy horizontal
scaling if you want to add new capacity
to your zones let's say we bring up a
whole new set of racks all we need to do
is spin up a new replica of our control
plane voila you have a new capacity we
can announce it is as simple as up
so as GCP has grown and our offerings
have expanded the network programming
has become more and more complex we
started off with a very simple model
it's a pre-programmed model it looks
something like this it's a full mesh it
is very simple consistent and
predictable to think about in latency
but it has one problem
there's quadratic scaling in terms of
VMC so anytime for a network if you're
going to add a new VM get to do this
full mesh that means here to go ahead
and program open flow rules in every
single VM host we can do better than
that
so we started looking the first thing we
evaluated with a traditional open flow
model but the control plane waits for
the first packet and based on the packet
we install our flows now this again is
much better than a pre-programmed model
but it is unpredictable latency and you
can imagine why it is dependent on the
control plane capacity it also exposes
the control plane to packet flops from
the packet floods from the hosts so what
we did is we combined the best features
of all these different things and we
came up with a model what we call
hoverboards hoverboards are a software
gateway and you can think of this as a
default router on your network we don't
need a pre program our flows as soon as
the PM's come up in a network the
packets start egressing ingressing
through the software gateway so there is
really no warmup time small networks
remain as before we borrowed this from
the pre program model as a mat I
mentioned before it is simple in it's
consistent for this hoverboards as if
Luis that are going through it were
larger we have also added the ability to
offload them directly back in the host
and this allows our software gateways to
scale as well as giving predictable
latency in throughput so from this I'm
gonna move on to the data plane now
so we working on this for a while the
first step was in dropping a 1.0 when
our data plane was in the kernel in a
rahat open me switch to that we added
offloads per performance when we
introduced live migration
this was Andromeda 1.5 next is what we
have the current version just to point
out there is a large evolution where we
move the entire data plane from the
to use a space but it came a huge boost
in performance and also a large increase
in release velocity and I'll be talking
about how that we achieve that in the
next few iterations to be pushing hard
and hypervisor bypass the first version
with working on right now is 2.1 which
allows the guest to s to bypass the
hypervisor and talk directly to a user
space neck in the future we'll have full
bypass where the guest OS will be
directly talking to hardware neck giving
you full hypervisor bypass so one of the
goals when we built this new data plane
Andromeda 2.0 was to enable native
hardware performance in software so the
way we did that is we introduced what we
call a fast path and a fast path has a
single CPU that's busy polling and it's
optimized for performance it can sustain
up to two million packets per second CPU
intensive operations you moved it off
the fast path into what we call core
processors core processors have this
unique ability to scale with the
technology we call CPR tribution and
finally all this is controlled by the on
host control plane using open V switch
so you might have a questions - why did
we build this in userspace initial
manage and treat distinct advantages the
first one is security our data plane
runs without any root privileges unlike
a monolithic kernel it also has a very
small attack surface because it's built
for one purpose so we can do continuous
fuzz testing on it it also is comes
built with a SLR and has that protected
Canaries to prevent against memory
corruption it also gives us improved
robustness so you can think of this if
you have a kernel networking stack bug
it'll take down your entire machine and
in this case it's a user space process
so it just come right up finally one of
the biggest advantages we have is rapid
releases we can upgrade the entire data
plane underneath without been having to
either live migrate to VMs or do a
machine brain it's not just performance
that we optimize for you also want a
fully program
airplane what I've shown here is a data
plane with a flow table now the flow
table can take a fight to pull or a
3-tuple key match and as extremely
extensible packin actions the VM
controller has full control over this it
can program it and in this case it is
programming you through open flow
through open V switch which is
programming let's see an end cap and a
decamp action we also have extended the
open V switch so we have google
extension frameworks that allows us to
provide stateful functions like sticky
load balancing you can do things like
stats and filtering and policy
enforcement directly inside the open V
switch we also have extended the
coprocessor api it's extremely
extensible we anything that requires
inline packet processing for example
traffic shipping Dawson abuse we have
built into it so inside the core
processor and I say API exposed as well
and any new features with actively
developing are getting implemented in
this coprocessor framework so next i'm
gonna talk about performance so what is
the advantage that you get when we moved
from a drama 1.0 onwards so first up to
put the improved throughput by over 5x
from Andromeda 1.0 to Andromeda 2.1 so
currently without throttling you can get
25 Gbps and affording the next set up
just note though customers are total at
16gb PS overall this is to provide
consistent performance across different
hardware platforms we also improve
latency tcp round-trip latency reduced
by 7x went by for me when we moved from
Andromeda 1.0 turned Rama a 2.1 finally
cpu efficiency we measure CP efficiency
it cycles verbatim and this combines the
receive side guest the receive side host
even the sender side pose in sender side
VM and we improved it by a factor of 8
giving more CPU the guest to use for
other functions and the dot we wrap up
the Andromeda section of this and I'll
be handing over to my colleague SR
wrestlin to discuss how we take the
software approach all the way to the
front
Thank You 3i I will be talking about how
this mmm cloud networking fits into the
Internet at large so where do we connect
to the internet this is a map behind me
here of where we have pops or points of
presence where we pair with other
networks our global network spans to the
world and then connected data centers
but to make it Sharia it's you truly
useful we want to connect it to ice
peace and be closer users we are peering
with ISPs at over 100 interconnection
facilities and at about 19 that exchange
points about 80 of those are used for
data balancing and City and features
that we'll talk about as an indication
of the distances here and being Network
folks we measure it in milliseconds so
Texas just did a third-party evaluation
of our CDN for for the cloud offering
and their numbers are that the median
latency for fetching an object from the
CDN is 42 milliseconds across the world
and the 90 percentile of that is hundred
and forty-eight so not that much higher
this and and like lots other things that
we do we care about the tail as well so
what does it look like this is an
example here behind me of what how you
would configure global load balancing in
in the Google Cloud one feature we have
is that we have a global IP address so
when you configure load balancer you get
one global IP address that is valid for
all the users and more importantly it
give gets good service to all the users
so this means you don't have to do any
DNS based on balancing the only thing
you need to do is put in a record in
your DNS server of the choice with that
address and as you can see on the
picture here you will your users will
get the red redirected will get content
from as nearby as we can make them so
the demo end-users get get get connected
to you Central and the Mumbai users get
connected to to an Asia region
regardless of anything you have to do
the only thing you have to do is to
make sure they use this IP address and
this is again like like my co-presenters
talked about before built on the
existing shared infrastructure that we
at Google used for all the Google
services that you are used to and nearby
the user we allow you to have a CDN it's
a one checkbox option if you want to
have CDN but your load balancing
offering we can do different routing on
a per request level on each URL and I
will talk more about that and the
latency matters for us latency matters
for users of web services we have known
this with but search for example for a
long time and those are matters for
micro services if you build your
infrastructure so that you're calling
different things being able to get back
soon it's important so that that's
something that we care about so this is
an overall picture of what looks like at
the edge your phone in the ISPs network
on the left here is connecting to your
global IP address we pair with this is P
is it very clear indirectly at some
point using the border gateway protocol
and in the edge pop we have a little bit
of infrastructure so that we can serve
cache content from there from the CDN
and we can terminate a TCP connection
from the user there which brings a
performance advantage in that it's a
shorter connection retransmits are much
faster and you get better performance of
it and then over on the right further
away from the user in the yellow case
you have your data center where you run
the actual VM jobs so I'll go into more
detail on these steps so the advantage
we're doing this in software like you
heard from a meetin three is that we are
very used to building systems that scale
out we build big we scale up the number
of components we can have a larger
larger amount of traffic large amount of
volume it scales with new hardware that
gets better and since the system is
built to deal with failures one of those
not being there we have to work around
that
and we keep going also this is a similar
mechanism that we used for pushing
updates we can take one component off we
can put a new version of banner to it
bring it back up again it gets part of
the mesh it gets running again and we
can do rolling upgrades that way without
anybody noticing that anything was down
so at some point we start with version X
and then slowly assuming everything goes
well when that with the version X plus
one with the new features and if
something goes well it doesn't go well
we just go back to version X again and
everything here being described here is
also integrated into the configuration
manager that's we talked about earlier
so all these components get orchestrated
together to make sure the whole data
plan works from end to end
so how does it work to have best one
global address but use usable from
anywhere mostly people talk about a
nanny caste address the large feature we
have done here does to make it
stabilized so that if things change and
routing changes over time that doesn't
have an impact the way this work
technically is is pretty simple we
announce a block of addresses to all our
peers for PDP for each isp they get to
figure out what routes do they have for
this block to reach to Google and
oftentimes it's a long list of different
ones they get to choose and they're
typically they choose the shortest path
which is the smallest number of hops but
they also have a number of other paths
they can use if that one isn't available
for some reason so in general your users
traffic ends up at the nearest pop by
network distance which should be not
that far away
and then there's a fallback if that pop
isn't available or it goes somewhere
else
Mac routing flaps which means that
routing changes over short periods of
times and goes back it's fairly common
which makes it hard to deal with these
any caste addresses for TCP in your own
so we have a special mechanism dealth
that we built to deal with that I'll
talk about later
so these are the things that we put in a
pop we have two routers for redundancy
but are the connections to the other
networks and then we have two two more
steps first we have a network level low
balancer that does routing on TCP
connections we call it maglev this is
something we built in-house so the
function of that is to map each incoming
users TCP connection to one or the next
of the boxes the GFE or Google fronting
for short is the HTTP base level so that
they are built so that is the first
level that can actually take the URL
apart and enact based on the full
console URL we install CDN in these
publications well so that for cash
content we can serve it very quickly
back and we don't even need to send it
to a data center so let's talk more talk
more about the Maglev the Maglev is
basically taking a five tuple hash and
mapping that to one instance of GFE so
that means that we keep that connection
at the same instance we have all the
cache content all the state and that
whole point as long as we can so the
goal is is to each user and in a lo bad
infection hits one particular GFE and
there's multiple mechanisms that go into
making that happen once we have
established the connection we keep track
of where we sent that particular user
and we'll keep sending it there to make
sure that's a stable connection if it's
a new connection so we haven't seen it
before then we use consistent hashing to
make sure we have a uniform way of
making that decision across the board
across this ever-changing set of load
balancers to deal with these round flat
players mentioned before each we have it
we have a map that says for each client
prefix where do we expect it to land and
if a maglev gets traffic that is isn't
supposed to land there will forward it
to the other maglev and once that route
flap isn't there anymore we'll keep code
it will use won't see any difference but
the other magnet will be doing the work
now
maglevs are only on the inbound pass so
all traffic goes back to you sir ghost
goes out directly which makes them more
efficient they only have a deal with one
side of the flow and if you do network
the network level low balancing for your
cloud features you can the Magnus will
be the one setting direct traffic
directly to your VMs and they get to
know what IP is to deal with from this
configuration manager that we talked
about before so these these are all
software runs which kernel back bypass
on normal servers and they can do this
at line rate so this is the flow for
each maglev for each incoming packet it
looks at a target IP address and says is
this an address I'm dealing with am i
doing low balance for this address if
not we can just drop it if it is look if
we look it up in this map it says for
this prefix it should be in this
location and if that location is not me
well I know where to send it I was
passed on to that one and that one will
do the right thing with it and this
we've rebuilt this client IP map so that
we know where to expect traffic and then
we look it up in the condition tracking
and says - have you seen traffic from
this client before if so when you know
where to send it if not we use
consistent hashing to figure out where
it should go and we annotate that in the
connection Tracking's of subsequent
packets on that inspection TCP
connection can go there directly the
next step is the in the edge pop is the
GFE it's a proxy or reverse proxy so it
terminates the TCP connection which as I
said before helps with making it a short
connection to the user and improving
latency and improving recovery time if
we get thing to drop packets on that
link it terminates HTTP and by HTTP I
mean the whole family or I should be
like protocols so one one - Oh G RPC is
a Google RPC system open source built on
top HTTP - oh and quick is basically the
next version we should be running on UDP
instead of TCP once it actually has to
fall host name in the URL it knows what
is cacheable and what's not
and they can consult the cash and see do
I have this object cash and if so I can
serve it from there directly it can also
do different things depending on the
full URL so you can have different
mappings for different parts to URL
space by default it will send traffic to
the nearest region - again to reduce
latency if that reading is at capacity
and that can't handle it we'll send it
somewhere else and that cap has can
either be you configure agent VM saying
hey this is how much traffic it can
handle or we can just look at the CPU
load and say oh well these VMs are
overloaded we should not send recently
more traffic and to reduce latency we
also health checked VMs at a time before
send them any traffic so we know that
they're up and healthy so that that
those requests don't have to wait so
here's an example assuming you have a
website where you have your assets your
images your HTML your CSS JavaScript
instead of serving them from a web
server you can just put him in a storage
bucket and tell us when you set up your
load balancer everything else ultra
static please go and fetch it it's in in
this storage package and that means that
we don't even need to go to your VM and
and all it about all about these
requests we can send them directly to
the storage which is you know scale a
little solution that that grows by
itself and you can have different Park
portions of the URL space can also get
sent to different different set of VMs
so if you have some some level of
different content for different
processing you can send it to different
places so this is the overall picture
the GFE over on the edge after having
consulted this CDN and knows it's not a
cache content it consults the global
opens or the bottom there which will
tell it well we have capacity in this
zone we have capacity in this zone and
the G fee also tells still the global
load controller how much traffic it has
sent so they can update its accounting
and not send too much traffic in each
zone on inside us own there's the health
checker that goes and checks the VMS
that are registered to be back in the
low bounce or to make sure that they are
healthy
and they'd reports that back to the
global load controller so he wouldn't
send traffic to a VM that is not up yet
we're not running a healthy from a
networking point of view the GFE looks
to your VMs like a normal machine on the
network it is using a public IP address
that's not routable and you can think of
it as GV is actually forming part of all
your V needs but if he can tell apart
one one from the other so from your VMs
and your web servers running on your VMs
point of view it just look like a normal
host on that network is sending it
traffic and this is all using the
virtual networking in from Andromeda
that three already talked about so to
tie this back what we really care about
and would like you to enjoy and your
users enjoy well is its low latency and
we have built this in multiple different
ways first of all we have an extensive
network of peering points so that we end
up being close to your users if we have
to if we can serve from CDN and we have
to go back to VM we'll go to a nearest
region again till it videos latency we
make sure everything is warmed up so
they usually have them a connection we
can we are ready to send it to all we
had on the handshakes and we know that
that VM is healthy and serving and we
can say that the request and we also
have done a bunch of work on different
protocols the list of HTTP family
protocols I listed earlier that are all
aimed at reducing latency so it's an
example here we did a blow test across
three different zones where we push it
pushed up the Lotus to 1.3 million
requests per second and to me the
impressive thing here is not that line
which is great but how you can see how
quickly were able to get to that line
right we were able to scale things up
very quickly now next up is amita's back
and it's going to talk to you how we
have built all kinds of different
networking project
products based on this infrastructure
thanks uh sir let's look inside the
software based design of some of our
networking products now first part I'll
talk about this cloud router and VPN BGP
and IPSec VPN is often used by
enterprises to provide multi-site
connectivity one of these sites can also
be your cloud provider in a typical
deployment VPN and BGP are in the same
hardware box BGP routing protocol
automatically learns about the changing
topology on the remote site and programs
the hardware box with forwarding
decisions for outgoing traffic and all
servers or VMs sent traffic to this box
which then encrypts and sends it to the
other side in DCP there is no hardware
box involved and BGP and VPN running
separate tasks providing control and
data plane separation cloud out a task
that runs BGP programs the learned
routes from the remote peer directly on
beams and 10 VMs to send traffic
directly to the right we pianned task
for those destinations which then sends
it to the other side
our implementation provides isolated and
customizable routing and VPN
functionality for each customer running
inside their own virtualized Network we
maintain a pool of free router and VPN
tasks which are ready to be allocated to
any virtual network when the request
comes when cloud weepin request comes it
is forwarded by a conflict manager to
the VPN manager which then allocates a
free task for this VPN information about
this allocated task is also sent to
fabric manager which then further
programs other modules downstream now in
the cloud router creation request comes
it is forwarded to a routing manager
which again allocates a free routing
task and the information is sent to
fabric manager for programming the data
plane at the end of this
there's a direct connectivity between
your VM router and VPN as part of your
virtual network now let's look at what
happens in case there is a failure if
for any reason the router task fails
routing manager identifies that and
allocates one more from the free pool
and also updates andromeda flows routing
manager and data path also preserves the
routes for bgp whole done so traffic is
not impacted internet load balancing
this is a typical multi-tiered
deployment for web services their
front-end web server for serving you
i'll static content backend application
and business layer for dynamic content
processing and both these layers need to
scale out with demand you configure
external load balancer of a public IP to
distribute requests to your front-end
instance front-end instances and
front-end will further need to
distribute these requests for dynamic
processing to one of the back-end
servers and we want to do this in load
balanced way and for this we provide
manage internal load balancing or
private IP here we compare how our
implementation differs from a typical
load balancer normally there is a
hardware box or task to which all
traffic is sent which then load balances
it between available buttons
now drawbacks for this approach are
single point of failure and load
balancer itself can become choke point
for handling all traffic therefore we
got rid of the middle box each client
using three or five tuple consistent
hashing picks a back-end for each
connection load balancers provision
inside each client as a customizable
network function internal node balancer
is fully programmable through API let's
look at the configuration flow in
addition to
components for configuration and control
plane we have seen so far there is
health checking infrastructure when
configured load balancer with list of
backends health check it is asked to
monitor their health updates are sent to
VM controller and based on those it
programmed client VMs with right load
balancing configuration client can then
sent traffic directly to the bagans now
to talk about network peering this is a
new feature which was recently released
in alpha and will be beta soon it allows
you to peer to networks so that VMS on
those networks can communicate with each
other common use case would be providing
software as a service our GCP platform
in this example say Google wants to
provide a cloud service to its consumers
consumer 1 and consumer 2 for reasons of
isolation billing model etcetera it is
preferred to spin up a separate network
hosting service instances for each
customer and then peer that network with
the corresponding consumer network at
this point each customer can access the
service Google provided for them across
a paired link peering works for networks
within the same organization as well as
across organization only restriction is
that sub network ranges in peering
networks should not overlap
peirong implementation provides
isolation with connectivity we talked
about vm controller earlier there is
endpoint manager in vm controller that
handles all the updates given to it by
fabric manager
it gives end points for each network to
a per network flow handler that creates
all the flows for that network now for
peering we made endpoint manager smarter
to understand peering configuration
which may network handlers aware of
endpoints in peer networks also this
network handlers then also create flows
for sending traffic to endpoints in peer
network but each network can still
control what kind of traffic they can
receive from peer network through
ingress firewall rules so this is how we
provide isolation with connectivity
peering was implemented as Network
function with quick feature turn around
by modifications in only the centralized
control plane in the Traverse daeun way
there are many more networking features
in DCP like multi neck hi PA racing
firewalls that we could not cover here
due to time but before closing I want to
introduce Google virtual private cloud
BBC Google provides unique VPC
characteristics it provides global
connectivity for VMs in multiple regions
so they can talk to each other or
private ip's it is shareable across
multiple projects and sub network ranges
can be extended with demand it also
provides access to Google services
without traversing public network there
is also full talk later in the evening
on this topic to summarize here are the
benefits of Google cloud platform it
provides on-demand access to compute
storage and networking high availability
and up times high throughput low latency
network functions as a service
it is built using same infrastructure
and innovations that power Google
services and we delivered products at
the speed of software to learn more
these are some of the other talks which
will be happening today evening or
tomorrow
[Music]
you